Итак, сгенерировали мы в Mijorn какую-то классную иллюстрацию, возможно, поправили её, делали это в небольшом разрешении или, например, в Cree. Мы искали свой стиль, генерировали в 1K разрешение, чтобы это, опять же, было быстро и получили такого слабенького качества картинку. Да и, в целом, разные модели, в частности, диффузионные, в частности, Cree, генерируют достаточно размытую, не слишком детализированную картинку даже в высоком разрешении.
Теперь нам нужно это, про апскейлить. Это, в целом, очень частый инструмент пайплайна. Тебе постоянно нужно улучшать качество изображения, но тут не так-то всё просто. Давай вообще поговорим о том, какой апскейл бывает, какие есть для этого инструменты и как ими правильно пользоваться.
Какие вообще есть основные проблемы у апскейла? Первое — это дорисованные детали. Разные модели апскейла, разные подходы по-разному дорисовывают детали. Некоторые не созданы для того, чтобы тебе там больше детализировать изображение.
Они делают это криво, косо, поэтому здесь важно правильно выбрать, что тебе нужно. Вторая проблема — это пластиковая кожа, либо кожа, как бы, покрытая такой чешуей. Возможно, сегодня мы увидим, как это выглядит.
Это о чём говорит? О том, что у нас либо недостаточная детализация именно текстур, либо, наоборот, избыточная. Здесь также нужно правильную модель использовать, адаптированную под это. Следующее — это сломанный текст. Ну, такая глобальная проблема, можно сказать.
Апскейлеры, прямо скажем, плохо дорисовывают текст. Если в каком-нибудь чате GPT, либо NanoBanana — это одна из основных киллер-фич, фич, с которой они продают свой инструмент, то апскейлеры, которые адаптированы именно на текст, то таких апскейлеров, которые говорят, что мы и то можем, и ещё текст тебе дорисовать и так далее, их нет.
Есть отдельные модификации апскейлеров, которые адаптированы именно под улучшение текста, но так, чтобы всё сразу на одном изображении, там тебе и лицо, и детали какие-нибудь на фоне, и текст. Такого нет.
И последнее — это изменённый бренд. Опять же, когда мы используем креативные апскейлеры, ну, сейчас мы ещё поговорим о том, какие они бывают, они могут изменить тебе освещение, в целом сами объекты, если они недостаточно были детализированы до этого, целую палитру и так далее.
Здесь важно правильно настроить апскейлер. И плавно переходим к тому, что апскейлер можно настраивать по умолчанию. Вот два типа апскейла — фейтфул и креатив.
Фейтфул — это такой, как бы, честный, то есть он пытается именно в деталях воссоздать то, что ты ему уже отдаёшь, а креатив — это тот апскейлер, который дорисовывает тебе детали, добавляет что-то новое,
то есть сам придумывает, что бы это могло быть, а не пытается улучшить то, что у тебя уже есть.
И здесь для апскейла мы можем выделить три инструмента — топаз, крио и магнифик.
Здесь отмечено, что топаз лучше работает с фейтфул, магнифик лучше работает с креатив, а крио — это универсал, он может и то, и то, в зависимости от того, как ты его настроишь.
Поэтому я использую его, сразу скажу. При этом и у топаза есть подмодели, которые и креатив, и фейтфул, и у магнифика есть подмодели.
Но глобально магнифик с креативом лучше справляется, топаз с более честной передачей, дорисовкой.
Что фейтфул усиливает, дорисовывает то, что у тебя уже есть, а креатив выдумывает, генерирует новые и так далее.
Мы сейчас еще посмотрим, как это выглядит.
Давай перейдем в крию и пропскейлим какое-нибудь изображение.
Вот мы в прошлом уроке нагенерили много различных изображений, и из-за того, что они были в первой модели крия, они такие достаточно мыльные, не слишком высокого разрешения.
Ну, это прям вот 4К. Давай, наверное, что-нибудь попроще возьмем, чтобы прям нагляднее было.
Давай вот возьмем вот это первое изображение с пальмой, которое вообще перерисовало все изображение.
Из-за этого у нас тут качество упало.
Берем его и нажимаем Upscale.
Итак, он сразу тебе предлагает запустить Upscale, но давай сначала разберемся, что у нас тут есть.
Во-первых, ты, конечно, можешь выбрать сразу формат Upscale, насколько нужно его увеличить.
Двухкратно, четырехкратно, максимально это, по-моему, 8К или сколько.
Но нам достаточно будет 2Х, чтобы уже увидеть качество.
Дальше.
Prompt.
Prompt позволяет модели, прежде чем там что-то дорисовывать, доделывать, понять, что вообще на изображении.
Если самостоятельно не хочешь описывать, нажимаешь туда Describe, он сам описывает, что у тебя на изображении.
Но здесь он почему-то взял тот prompt, который был входным для дорисовки.
Поэтому здесь придется самостоятельно описать, что у нас на изображении.
Спортивный автомобиль Corvette на теннисном корте, на заднем фоне пальма, на самом корте теннисные мячики.
Все, я это описал и переведу на английский язык на всякий случай.
Первое, это силы и то, насколько он будет дорисовывать то, что у тебя уже есть.
Это как раз таки тот параметр креативности, о котором я говорил.
Если в отдельных моделях он, грубо говоря, фиксированный, то здесь, именно в Enhancer, Cree или Upscaler его можно варьировать.
Я хочу добавить новых деталей, поэтому поставлю здесь 80%, например.
И идем дальше.
Resemblance влияет на то, насколько честным как раз таки будет результат.
Вот у нас здесь как раз этот Faithful есть.
Почему я говорил, что нужно запоминать Faithful, InPaint, OutPaint и так далее.
Вот все эти формулировки.
Потому что они у тебя здесь встречаются в таком виде, когда ты работаешь с новым E-инструментом, тебе непонятно, что вообще для чего служит.
Если здесь еще половина интерфейса понятна, то в каком-нибудь VIVI там вообще нужно будет это все искать самостоятельно.
Давай Resemblance поставим побольше, например, тоже там процентов 90.
Clarity — это то, насколько он будет менять изображение.
Он может изменить цвет, может изменить освещение и так далее.
Здесь мы поставим поменьше, потому что мы хотим как бы стилистически это изображение сохранить.
И Sharpness в конечном итоге просто резкость твоего изображения.
У нас здесь дымка появилась ненужная.
Давай чуть-чуть добавим этого Sharpness.
И если хотим, чтобы у нас по цветам точно все совпадало, можем еще дополнительно Match Color здесь поставить и нажать InHand.
Давай параллельно еще запустим с минимальным Resemblance и посмотрим, как будет отличаться результат.
Итак, смотри.
Само по себе изображение у нас достаточно как бы размытое, мутное, без четких очертаний.
И поэтому, если его заставлять максимально придерживаться исходника, то он будет запутываться, что ему вообще нужно делать.
При том, что AI Strand у нас стоит большой достаточно.
Мы его попросили с помощью И многое додумать, но при этом сказали ему придерживайся строго того, что есть.
Из-за этого у нас получилось вот такое размытое изображение.
Он старался оставить все те же самые формы, но не понял, как их нормально доработать.
Если же мы поставили Resemblance на 0, то здесь у нас поменялся, во-первых, цвет, поменялся цвет, поменялась вообще растительность.
То есть она даже по контуру не везде совпадает, но при этом она очень четкая.
Все максимально четко пририсовано, корт, мячики, текст, например, вообще по-другому расположен, иначе выглядит.
То есть здесь мы дали ему пространство для свободы, и он дал нам больше четкости.
Все выглядит лучше, ну за исключением вот этого.
Здесь мы силу И можем подубавить, и оно будет получше выглядеть.
Вот передняя часть автомобиля, все четко здесь совпадает, но маленько он дорисовывает все-таки дополнительные детали.
Пальма вообще как бы другой формы.
Здесь у нас, в принципе, на корте появляется еще забор.
Здесь какая-то желтая еще фигня, дополнительный человек.
То есть она многое додумывает, вот этот столб вообще в пальму превратила тоже на заднем фоне, но при этом четкость дает очень хорошую.
Давай теперь то же самое попробуем сделать, но убавим силу ИИ.
Итак, давай посмотрим, что у нас получилось.
И у нас в разумных 20% мы не говорим ему, чувак, я сейчас все перерисую, я хочу, чтобы ты все переработал.
Там, где этого вообще, в принципе, не нужно.
Дальше.
Resemblance у нас 10%.
Мы не ставим 0, но чуть-чуть добавляем, чтобы он все-таки ориентировался на исходник, а не максимально свободно перепридумывал то, что уже есть.
Также немного добавил Clarity, дал ему чуть-чуть свободы, чтобы он мог что-то дорисовать, где ему непонятно, что происходит.
И Sharpness оставил на том же сам показатель.
И смотри, что у нас получается.
Здесь у нас все идеально совпадает, четкость у нас отличная, все столбы отрисовываются, все растения там, где они должны быть.
Изображения идеально отрисовываются, диски.
Здесь у нас маленько путаются в деталях, не очень понятно.
Если приглядываться, то видно, что ИС генерировал, но это вопрос к модели, которая генерировала, а не к апскейлеру.
Здесь у нас у каждого мячика отрисовались ворсинки.
Текст плюс-минус там же, где он должен быть.
Четкость очень высокая, при том, что мы только 2х ставили.
Можем сейчас вообще 4х поставить, и будет отлично выглядеть.
Арка, диск, все канты, все у нас здесь прекрасно совпадает.
Тут у нас тоже было мыло, все теперь стало четенько.
Зеркало тоже у нас отрисовывается.
Все максимально четко, красиво, аккуратно выглядит.
Здесь он даже что-то покреативил, потому что, опять же, смазано было изображение этих тормозов.
Тут тоже фара значительно четче стала.
Все у нас выглядит аккуратно, все совпадает по форме, по деталям.
И здесь, опять же, вот он не стал дорисовывать какие-то лишние заборы, какие-то непонятные элементы.
Он только дополнил то, что уже есть.
Получился отличный, качественный результат.
Здесь только какой-то вот этот парень непонятно и на исходнике выглядит с каким-то плащом.
Одноногий пират.
Ну и здесь он тоже не понял, как это дорисовать, эту фигуру.
Ее вообще надо было удалить.
Таким образом мы проапскейлили и получили отличное изображение.
Смотри, по поводу Cree Enhance, что мы уже сейчас можем отметить?
Первое.
Все эти показатели, во-первых, нужно понимать, как они работают.
Если ты забыл мое объяснение, наводишь, читаешь, что здесь написано.
Второе.
Эти показатели лучше не выкручивать в максимальные, либо в минимальные значения.
Тогда модель не очень понимает, как себя вести.
Ты лишаешь ее определенной доли свободы и как бы не направляешь, не объясняешь, что тебе нужно сделать.
Оставишь в жесткие рамки или заставляешь делать избыточную работу.
И получается, ну такой вот довольно странный результат, как мы здесь можем убедиться.
И самое главное, Cree Enhance мы можем использовать и как fateful модель, и как креативную, в зависимости от того, как мы ее настроим.
Но настроить сперва бывает непросто.
Здесь нужно покрутить эти ползунки.
Но когда ты разберешься, как это работает, этого инструмента будет тебе достаточно для, я не знаю, 99,9% всего апскейла, который тебе нужно сделать.
С Cree upscaler мы разобрались.
Давай посмотрим, что еще у нас здесь есть.
У нас есть Tapas, есть Magnific.
Здесь описаны стоимости этого апскейла.
Стоимость достаточно большая.
Описано также, для чего эти модели нужны и какое у них предельное значение апскейла.
Обрати внимание, что Cree Enhance тратит всего 20 токенов.
При том, что там Tapas Generative, Tapas Bloom, 250, 150 и больше токенов.
Давай теперь воспользуемся Creative и Faithful апскейлером.
Мы знаем, что Magnific представляет лучшие креатив апскейлеры.
Здесь так и написано, Best Creative.
Максимум до 10к.
Давай возьмем его и посмотрим, как он улучшит это изображение.
Также берем наш исходник.
И здесь у нас есть уже небольшие отличия.
Во-первых, 2x4x.
Здесь у нас меньше возможностей для апскейла.
10к – это максимальное разрешение изображения.
Здесь же вот мы можем 2x4x устанавливать апскейл.
Пока давай оставим 2x.
Описание у нас сохранилось.
Стиль.
Здесь удобно, что уже есть, можно сказать, преднастройки у этой модели внутри нее.
Ты можешь выбрать сразу, что ты улучшаешь.
Это портреты, иллюстрации, видеоигры.
Я выберу фильмы и фотографии.
Мне это больше здесь подходит.
Дальше здесь можно выбрать engine, то есть какой движок для апскейла у тебя используется.
В целом лучше ставить автоматик.
Он сам подбирает.
В целом в эти тонкости лучше не лезть.
Выбираем автоматик и двигаемся дальше.
Здесь уже более понятный формат.
Creativity так и написано.
Можем выбирать, насколько креативной будет модель.
Выберем максимум.
Ну ладно, давай не максимум.
Выберем 7, чтобы все-таки какой-то более-менее адекватный был результат.
HDR я трогать не буду, потому что он может испортить изображение.
Resemblance, опять же, то, насколько будет соответствовать исходнику наше изображение.
И Fractality, то, насколько детализированными будут текстуры.
Но я хочу добавить четкости.
Сделаем, например, 4.
Ну и давай сразу апскейл делаем на 4х и посмотрим, что он нам создаст.
Это у нас креативный апскейлер.
Давай параллельно с этим запустим Faithful.
Выберем стандартный Tapas.
Он подешевле, чем Magnific.
Здесь у нас не так много параметров.
Также 2х, 4х, 8х и так далее.
Сделаем также 4х.
Sharpness, то, насколько резким будет изображение.
Добавим немного.
De-noise, это убрать шум.
Тоже немного подуберем его.
Модель стандартная.
Для низкого разрешения CGI, то есть графика.
И High Fidelity, максимальным разрешением, мы оставим просто стандарт V2.
Также Subject Detection.
Чему конкретно нужно больше внимания уделить?
Тому, что на фоне, либо на переднем плане.
Нам нужно проапскейлить все, поэтому здесь мы это оставляем.
И также есть параметр Face Enhancement.
Мы знаем, что это точный, честный апскейлер.
И помимо того, что он обучен делать это, то есть дорабатывать изображение правдоподобно,
он еще может более точечно, более внимательно работать с лицами, если они в кадре есть.
Эта штука часто спасает, потому что лица апскейлера достаточно часто меняют.
Здесь включаем эту галочку и устанавливаем креативность.
Сильно нужно поменять внешность персонажа или нет,
то насколько сильно нужно дорабатывать именно лицо, тоже отдельно можно настроить.
Но здесь у нас лиц нет, поэтому мы просто это выключим.
Все, параметры мы все настроили, достаточно базово.
Давай запустим апскейл и посмотрим, что у нас будет.
Итак, сейчас мы посмотрим, что называется креативным апскейлом.
Вы сразу поймете, о чем речь.
Ну, как видим, здесь он крайне сильно проапскейлил наше изображение,
очень сильно его доработал, очень много деталей добавил.
Здесь у нас появились прям очень четкие, здесь у нас появились четкие логотипы.
Ну, сами мечи, да, он не воспринял как какой-то объект, он не знает, как его дорисовать,
поэтому тут лишнего накреативил.
Ворс, прям каждую ворсинку видно, каждую деталь.
Вот этот странный кривой объект он дорисовал,
ну, постарался чуть больше сделать похожим на какой-то воздухозаборник, да,
уже как-то это выглядит получше.
Тут с дверной ручкой он накосячил,
сделал странный переход между отражениями.
Диск он практически идеально восстановил,
это уже, ну, похоже на настоящий диск.
Здесь на фоне вообще как-то очень сильно дорисовал сам теннисный корт,
кстати, добавил еще зеркало лишнее.
Вот мы, кстати, можем увидеть, что здесь вот этот плавник,
он обычно находится на крыше, да, автомобиля.
А зеркало, ну, его тут точно не может быть.
Он не понял, что здесь у нас именно спойлер.
И попытался из каких-то объектов,
которые там связаны в его памяти с машинами,
воссоздать вот эту форму.
Потому что, опять же, это диффузионная модель.
Она не думает, она не точечно отрисовывает,
она только воспроизводит как бы нечто похожее,
созвучное с тем, что у нее в памяти есть.
Точно так же здесь вроде как все красиво, да,
четко, аккуратно, но если мы тут посмотрим,
здесь еще какое-то колесо появляется, да,
новая колесная арка.
Здесь, например, этого не было.
И такие артефакты, они, конечно, имеют место быть.
Особенно, когда креативность у тебя выкручена достаточно сильно, целых 8.
Здесь он уже на все деньги, как говорится, начинает дорисовывать.
Тем не менее, если близко это все дело не рассматривать,
выглядит очень красиво.
Очень много здесь он дорисовал.
Не везде, конечно, адекватно.
Тут вот опять у нас какие-то лишние детали и прочее.
Колесо он отрисовал вообще идеально.
Дальше двигаемся.
Здесь у нас уже зеленеет почему-то автомобиль.
Здесь этот диффузор вообще максимально простой.
И тут он дорисовал каких-то новых дополнительных деталей,
какого-то карбона и прочего.
Здесь у нас гладкий переход.
Он тут дорисовал еще какие-то дополнительные формы.
Тут еще один шильдик.
Короче, он здесь очень сильно постарался.
И фару даже, вот видите, насколько точно он отрисовал,
насколько много деталей добавил.
Ну и в целом выглядит очень сочно это все дело.
Пальма вообще из вот такого мыла превратилась в супер детализированную.
Здесь у нас летает мячик, какой-то забор и прочее.
Здесь, кстати, мы прям видим четкие переходы того, как он рисовал.
Здесь какого-то чувака добавил.
Ну и в целом здесь прям видны вот эти пятна.
Здесь какой-то лишний переход.
Но вот так издалека выглядит, конечно, очень красиво.
Доработать это все еще можно, правильно выстраивая здесь параметры,
сильно его не перегружая.
И сравним с тем, что у нас сделал Tapas.
Мы помним, что это честный апскейлер.
Что у нас здесь?
Все он постарался максимально передать схожим с оригиналом.
Все у нас четко, аккуратно.
Не такой впечатляющий результат, как предыдущий,
но на предыдущем он прям уж дорисовывал это изображение, улучшал его.
Здесь же он просто постарался сделать его четче и аккуратнее.
Ну и в целом это видно, да.
Все линии, все изгибы, все у нас собрано аккуратно.
Пальма до этого мыла.
Сейчас, нормальная.
Он ни один объект не удалил, ничего не переместил.
Просто постарался честно воссоздать то, что уже есть, просто улучшив качество.
И Magnifico еще раз я запустил с меньшей креативностью, креативностью 2.
Здесь он постарался также все сохранить, но при этом дорисовать то,
что ему кажется каким-то размытым, невнятным, непонятным.
И это на самом деле прям такая золотая середина.
Когда мы используем прям Faithful, у нас, возможно, какие-то артефакты, которых быть не должно, остаются на нашем изображении.
Когда мы используем креативную и перекручиваем значение креативности, он дорисовывает то, чего быть не должно, например.
Здесь же какое-то у нас есть невнятное пятно.
Нужно покреативить и отрисовать, что это могло бы быть.
Это, в его понимании, могла бы быть машина.
Faithful вообще париться не стал.
Просто как-то это пятно дорисовал.
Что это такое, он сам не понимает.
Ну, наверное, какая-то пушка.
Креативный апскейлер, он постарался понять, что это могло бы быть, и дорисовать конкретный объект.
За это, конечно, ему плюват.
В целом, по очертаниям, он достаточно хорошо дорисовывает, отлично передает все.
Здесь текст, ну, также какие-то просто несколько полосок он решил превратить в уже что-то более похожее на текст.
Здесь вот он, к сожалению, уже лишнее дорисовал.
Дальше идем.
Он знает, что тут есть отражение.
Но что на этом отражении, вообще непонятно.
Поэтому он сам дорисовывает какие-то деревья.
Дорисовал здесь еще, кстати.
Дорисовал, кстати, здесь еще вот этот габарит, или как это называется.
То есть, опять же, он знает, мы окружены деревьями, лесами.
Вот он и дорисовывает какое-то дерево в отражении.
То есть, он не просто уточняет, он именно думает.
Спойлер у нас остался без изменений, но тут у нас достаточно странный переход.
И тут тоже он этот странный переход сохранил, да.
Вот этот вроде как диффузор, непонятно, то ли топливный бак, то ли диффузор.
Он постарался, опять же, в какой-то более адекватной форме отрисовать уже что-то более похожее, воссоздать.
Диск из вот этого вообще невнятного пятна он сделал.
Нормальный диск.
Дальше.
Тут у нас тоже непонятное наслоение.
Он дорисовал.
Все геометрически выглядит правильно.
Дверная ручка.
Здесь, ну, просто какая-то каракуля, пятно.
Здесь это, ну, адекватная дверная ручка.
В общем, он здесь все максимально четко дорисовал.
Салон вообще вот из этих пятен.
Он создал нормальный салон.
Зеркало.
Передняя часть.
Здесь вот у нас, например, да, даже неправильная геометрия какая-то.
Странные пятна.
Тут он все это выровнял.
Дорисовал.
Добавил деталей.
Отражения.
Здесь тоже какие-то волны.
Он, ну, какую-то геометрию постарался воссоздать.
Добавил деталей на фары.
Здесь у нас тоже эта штука обрывается.
Он ее дорисовал аккуратно и сделал.
Дорисовал вот этот шильдик.
Тут еще лишний добавил, правда.
Ну, и получился хороший, прям красивый, качественный результат.
Здесь постарался догадаться, что это все-таки за таинственная фигура.
Сделал, добавил одного бегуда на фон других пробегающих.
И как будто уже там более правдоподобно, да, это выглядит.
Ну, и здесь пальму, опять же, он отрисовал очень хорошо.
Очень красиво она встроена в окружение.
Вообще не догадаешься, что она тут отдельно была дорисована.
Итак, поэтому, какой вывод у нас при использовании моделей отдельных,
специализирующихся на отдельном подходе?
Faithful либо Creative.
Всего хорошо в меру, так же, как и при работе с Крией.
Если у тебя уже хорошего качества изображения, нормального,
но тебе нужно еще больше,
бери Faithful, просто дорисуй аккуратненько,
чтобы ничего не менять, и оставляй его.
Если изображение сомнительного качества,
возможно, у тебя геометрия где-то поехала,
возможно, у тебя вообще все размыто, просто пятна,
бери креативную модель и не перебарщивай с креативностью,
добавь ее немного так, чтобы она дополнила,
улучшила изображение, а не полностью его перерисовала.
И общий вывод в том, что специализированные модели
дают лучший результат,
но и стоят они дороже.
Можно ли того же самого добиться от Крии?
В целом можно,
но придется прям неплохо попотеть,
чтобы выстроить вот все эти ползунки
и найти оптимальный под конкретное
твое изображение вариант.
То есть, если ты один раз найдешь вот эту комбинацию,
не факт, что при апскеле следующего изображения
оно подойдет.
Здесь же модели специализированы,
они под это неоднократно обучены,
они отдельно продаются,
поэтому и результат они, конечно, будут давать лучше.
Ну и помимо этого классического магнифика,
классического топаза,
есть еще ряд дополнительных инструментов.
Например, мы знаем, что магнифика – это креативная модель,
но и у магнифика есть подмодель Precise,
то есть более честный вариант магнифика,
максимум 10к изображения.
И топаз, если у нас в классическом виде
фейтфул модель,
есть, например, топаз генерейтив и топаз блум,
которые являются креативными моделями.
Но я думаю, общий вывод ясен,
что если ты распыляешься на все,
то ты, скорее всего, все делаешь хуже,
чем те, кто сфокусированы на одном.
Соответственно, магнифик круто делает креатив,
используем для креатива магнифик.
Топаз круто делает честный результат,
используем именно его для этого.
Если хочешь поэкспериментировать,
конечно, можешь взять,
попробовать дополнительно эти модели.
Но они будут лучше справляться,
как бы от раза к разу.
Ну и если хочешь сделать дешево,
быстро, берем Crea Enhance
и настраиваем самостоятельно ползунки.
Когда наберешь руку, наберешься опыта,
уже станет понятно сразу на вскидку,
что ставить,
и будешь с первого раза получать
на приемлемый результат.
Я чаще всего использую именно Crea,
потому что она практически не ест токены,
потому что у нее тонкая настройка,
и она делает все намного быстрее.
Но если нужно прям качество-качество,
то иду уже в специализированные инструменты
Magnificatopass.
Также Magnificatopass можно отдельно приобрести.
Какие-то из них работают как
Mijor, не только в браузере,
в браузерных приложениях.
Какие-то вообще можно на свой компьютер
локально скачать.
Но для апскейла покупать отдельное приложение
я, честно говоря, не вижу смысла.
Только если ты профессионально этим занимаешься,
постоянно что-то апскейлишь.
А так в целом агрегатора,
такого как Crea,
за головой хватает для этих мушт.
На этом все.
В качестве домашнего задания
тебе нужно выбрать одно изображение.
То, которое ты делал в Crea,
в Mijorny,
либо когда мы разбирались с JSON.
Взять его и проапскейлить отдельно.
В Tapaz, Magnifici и в Crea.
Сравнить три этих результата
и кратко написать о своем опыте.
На этом все.
Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания
и до встречи в следующем уроке.